contre est que le poker fragile c'est
bien connu philippe l'état dresse le
portrait d'un homme monsieur dont ont le
sourire h difficile à décrire pour moi
c'est un homme surtout d'une grande
élégance morale et physique c'était
avant d'être un acteur ce qu'ils qu'il
était dans mon film c'était surtout un
impôt est surexcité son dernier film
personne katia ses premiers pas au
théâtre des amandiers
il n'aimait pas notre monde il lui
reprocher beaucoup de choses et en
particulier sa dureté il avait trouvé
des refuges dangereux dangereux pour lui
moi je garde de lui un souvenir très
très généreuses et il se mettait en
danger mais mais en même temps il
donnait beaucoup à tous ceux avec
lesquels il travaillait le poète de la
décadence
l'artiste au nez rouge j'ai toutes mes
amies mauvais jolies jantes et la vie
chante et des femmes
il ya eu quelques histoires d'amour
flamboyante est sublime dans sa vie mais
y quand un amour se brisait il se
pardonnait pas la limite de ne pas y
survivent d'y survivre
il aurait voulu mourir avec cet amour
tout ça bouchard tous à vos chats
charles bouchard tout ça a mûri
et finir en clochard académiciens
l'achat ni moratoire dans le pré vous
bien ça tombe le plein coeur un guerrier